Hello everybody.
Hello.
I am alive.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I fucked up.
So...
Let me tell you about today's schedule.
So you guys know...
After this stream, we are going to go straight to another stream.
Because...
I saw that Tempo...
He has...
Tempo is literally the main Apex Legends tournament organizer.
For every tournament in Apex.
So I saw Tempo...
On Monday.
I was like, oh hey, quiet up.
I was like, hey Tempo, can I join?
He was like, yeah.
I thought it says July 20th.
Because the sign up showed up on Monday.
So I was like, alright.
I was like, alright.
I'm thinking...
Oh yeah, that Apex Legends tournament...
That got announced on Monday...
Will be next month.
I thought it says July 29th.
Because usually...
I thought...
Usually it's organized way ahead of time.
So like...
Every time...usually in the past when there's sign ups...
They're not right off this week.
By the way.
So...
Because...
You know how I found out it was today?
Like...
I think like 2-3 days...
I think like 2 days ago?
Yeah, it was 2 days ago.
I was like messaging my staff members.
I was like, hey, do I have anything on July 29th?
I was like, hey, I want to make sure...
I don't overlap with anything on July 29th.
Because I feel like I have something on July 29th.
And then they're like...
Doki, this says June.
This is tomorrow.
I was like...
Wait, what?
They're like...
Because one of my staff members is like...
Asia.
And then I have another that's like EU.
And they're like, Doki, this says tomorrow.
Because for them it's tomorrow.
So they're like, that's tomorrow.
I was like, no, it's not.
It's July.
They're like, no, it's June.
And I'm like, it's June?
So I was like, oh fuck, okay.
It's June.
It's literally today.
So I was just like...
Oh fuck.
It's June 29th.
It's not July 29th.
So...
Anyway, this is...
Oh no!
Temple usually when he puts up a sign up sheet...
The tournament isn't...
This week.
It's usually like...
Like in two to three weeks.
So in my head I was like...
I didn't even know...
That hide and seek Nokia shit...
We were signed up like...
Two months ago for that.
The Nokia hide and seek thing.
I was signed up to that thing...
Two months ago before it happened.
So like...
In my head...
I was like, there's no way it's this late.
There's no way.
Anyway, I appreciate Temple for inviting me.
Anyway...
Not so Deadpool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
New model.
New skin suit.
Still illiterate.
Still the goat.
Never change.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Darkblade.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Just like the dragoons.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
Anyway...
So I was just like...
Oh shit.
It's...
Today technically.
It's today.
So this is my schedule.
I need you guys to know...
This is what my schedule is like today.
So this...
Whenever it's time for that other thing.
The apex thing.
We go straight to that.
By the way, I haven't touched apex since the last invitational that I was part of.
Which I mean I did try to warm up like today.
I did two warm up games.
I was like that's good enough.
Um...
And Temple's...
In the sign up sheet for the tournament.
They're like what rank are you?
Like what's your highest rank?
I put diamond.
Because at that point I was like... I don't...
I haven't touched a game in long ass time.
At least just consider me diamond level at that point.
Anyway...
Um...
Anyway as I was saying.
After that I have like a little intermission.
Until I have to go to Avcon.
I have to do Avcon.
Which is the Adelaide convention.
But that is like...
We go around artist alley at Avcon.
And then after going around artist alley at Avcon.
Uh...
We're going to the paddle.
And after doing the paddle.
We're going to be doing meet and greets.
And after meet and greets I sleep.
And after I sleep we do the Dokomi paddle.
Which is at 7.30 am my time.
Hehehehe.
Poro thank you for the 10k subs.
Thank you.
So my Dokomi paddle is tomorrow.
At 7.30 am.
And then after the Dokomi paddle.
We're going to go around the Dokomi artist alley.
And then after that I die.
I pass out.
Hehehehe.
So...
That is my schedule.
For today.
Hehehehe.
It leads all the way.
Till the next day.
Um...
Yes I...
Did not schedule myself quite well today.
Hehehehe.
I did not.
Because I forgot how to read today.
Hehehehe.
I literally signed up for Tempo's thing.
Because I thought it was next month.
I didn't know it was this week.
I believe I would have said yes.
I would have reached out to Tempo.
And be like hey I want to join.
Hehehehe.
Um...
Anyway but it's going to be a blast.
Like yesterday I did Avcon.
I was at Adelaide.
Well I wasn't at Adelaide.
I was virtually at Adelaide.
So I did...
I was at Adelaide.
Avcon yesterday.
So yesterday... Today is going to be day 2 of it.
Yesterday...
Um...
Yesterday we did a...
We couldn't do the gaming session.
Because apparently the internet died or some shit.
Or like got fucked up during the gaming session.
So...
We couldn't do the gaming with the...
Dragoons yesterday.
But we did karaoke.
And meet and greets.
Oh my god karaoke.
There was no feedback.
There was no like audio feedback or anything.
So I had no...
So I was like...
For those who were like no FOMO.
Anyway I'll talk to you guys a bit about the Avcon.
It was so funny.
So I had no audio feedback.
It was literally my very first karaoke slash concert.
For it.
Because I...
Because since I had no audio feedback.
I was like...
Thumbs up if it's okay.
Because I can't hear what's going on.
So I was like...
Give me a thumbs up.
If everything is okay.
So all the trackers are giving me thumbs up.
I was like...
Alright cool sweet.
Okay.
There was no...
Yeah so I had no audio feedback.
At first I had no visual feedback.
And then one of the technician guys like got their phone.
Because we are all in this like discord channel.
They got their phone.
And then turned their camera on on their phone.
So I could like...
I was like watching like what's going on.
On like somebody's phone.
Because there is no camera on the stage.
So I was just like...
Alright let's see what's going on.
And the guy was just bringing their phone.
And walking around with their phone.
Just to show you what's going on.
It was so funny.
Haha.
NetBurst thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Medisound guy can't save you now.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It was really funny.
Anyways I actually for those who weren't there.
I saw there was photos going around.
In some of the recordings.
I had exclusive videos made.
Just for like the karaoke concert thing.
Because you know I'm 2D.
Because it's not like a 3D thing.
It was like 30 minutes.
And my events manager was like.
I was like asking my.
Because I've never done the karaoke thing before.
I've never done like singing at a convention before.
Like live.
So I was like.
To my events manager.
I was like how long.
How many songs do I have to do for like 30 minutes.
And then my events manager was like.
Oh it's like 5 songs.
And I was like alright 3 songs.
Hahaha.
I'm gonna do like 3 songs.
And then I'm gonna pad it out with like half a pad.
I'm gonna just talk.
Hahaha.
I was like alright.
I'm pretty sure I can do 3 songs in 30 minutes.
And just like talk the rest of it.
And.
Hahaha.
So.
Every in between songs.
I was just like talking.
And I'm like padding out the time slot.
I made it in 30 minutes.
I got it correct.
I like estimated the time perfectly.
Okay.
Anyway those videos I'm gonna be using it for anime expo too.
Because like.
I mean it paid for the videos.
So it might as well.
Like it paid for the visuals.
For the karaoke.
So I'm gonna use it for anime expo as well.
And I mean I sing.
I have to sing like an hour.
Hahaha.
And then after that.
And then after that the stream.
People might be able to see it.
I don't know.
Maybe in the next karaoke at 800k.
It depends.
It really.
It really depends.
I wanna make it more show like.
Cause like.
I guess like if you're going to a convention.
You get like the exclusive sneak peek.
Before I actually use it on stream.
Um.
But that's.
That was basically the karaoke.
And then like the meet and greet.
I went an hour over time.
Because there were so many Australian dragoons.
I was so excited.
I was so surprised.
Um.
There were people that were not from Australia.
That came to the Avcon.
And I'm just like.
Guys it's a world tour.
Don't worry.
I might come over.
Hahaha.
I saw one of the dragoons here.
Um.
Who literally flew from the US.
To go to Avcon.
To see me.
And I was like.
Oh my god.
I don't want to call you out.
I mean you can like reveal yourself if you want to.
Hahaha.
But there was like dragoons.
That flew from the US.
And there was dragoons from like.
There was like dragoons from Japan.
That came over.
Like Japan.
Singapore.
Malaysia.
Hong Kong.
Like they were like.
Yeah.
Cause like.
Okay.
There was one.
I think it was like an American accent.
Like um.
A dragoon American accent.
Was like at meet and greet.
Like that's not Australian?
Where are you doing here?
I swear.
I was like where you doing here?
That's not an Australian accent.
Hahaha.
I was really like.
I flew from America.
I was like oh my god.
What the fuck?
I was like wait a minute.
It's for Australian.
Australian dragoons.
How did you get here?
Um.
It was actually crazy.
I was so happy to meet all the dragoons.
Like I said, I went like... I think like when the first guy came over for the meet and greet, they were like, there's a lot of people because it's free.
The meet and greet was free.
Like I don't earn anything from it.
At best I earn from the... there's like exclusive merch at the convention.
Some collector's card or something.
That's like the only thing.
And even then I don't...
I think like I make like $200, I think.
Or $400?
I don't remember.
Because it's like limited amounts.
So like if we sold everything, I would make like around $200 or $400, I think.
But like the... I just wanted like just something a little bit like a little momentum of like conventions.
And something from the conventions and stuff.
But like... what was I gonna say?
But yes, anyway.
The meet and greet was free.
And it was just like you just line up.
That's really it.
For Avcon.
And basically when the first Dragoon was there for the meet and greet.
I was like, how many people are there?
And he was like, oh like 50.
I was like, what the fuck?
And this was day one.
There's gonna be a day two for a meet and greet.
And then they're like, there's like around like 50.
And then they like took the webcam and like showed me the line.
I was like, oh my god.
How is there so...
It's Adelaide.
I'm sorry for people who live in Adelaide.
But like we were all...
Okay.
You were joking with me.
You guys said it to me first.
A lot of the Adelaide Australian Dragoons were like, why are you here?
It's Adelaide.
A lot of the Australian Dragoons were like, why are you here?
Like we were so...
They're like, I'm surprised you're here.
It was apparently Adelaide.
It was like, why are you here?
It's like a small city compared to...
Um...
Compared to like Sydney or Melbourne.
And I was just like, well, they invited me so I'm here.
Oh my god.
It was more than 50.
I don't know.
I don't know how many Dragoons I met, but I went an hour overtime.
Cause like, uh, when it was like supposed to end, one of the staff members was like, are you able to go overtime?
Because there's like 20 plus more Dragoons in line.
They're like, we cut it off now.
But like, there's still 20.
And I was just like, you know what you guys, there's 20 plus Dragoons like lined up for an hour.
I feel so bad turning them away after an hour.
So, uh, so I went on for longer than I think I went out for two hours and a half.
I don't, I don't remember.
I was so tired by the end.
After, after the meet and greet, I like, I don't, I just, I just went to bed.
I didn't do it.
No, I made my bed.
I made my waiting room after the meet and greet.
And then I went to bed.
Um, but it was very fun.
I had like an amazing time.
I felt bad because sometimes I'm the reason why like people, okay.
Cause like, I think it was like three minutes.
They changed it a bit because they didn't realize how many Australian Dragoons were going to be there.
I was so surprised too, because like, um, I know like VTubers don't come to Australia a lot.
Um, especially for like meeting.
And greets and stuff.
Uh, so like, uh, had a lot of Australian Dragoons that were like, oh my God, you were like the first VTuber we've I've ever met because like nobody comes here, especially Adelaide.
I'm like, yeah, that's why it's a world tour.
It's a world tour.
I wanted to be everywhere.
And, um, um, um, it was really fun though being, and then being able to meet so many Dragoons.
And like, like I said, like, uh, one person flew from like, they're like Australian.
One person flew out from outside of Adelaide.
And they, they're like, they like to me, they were like, I'm so tired.
I just got here today.
And then after this meet and greet, I'm flying back.
And I'm like, what?
Oh my God.
For me?
I was like, put on a pack.
Anyway, like one of the Australian dragons literally like flew in on the day.
Like they arrived in the morning.
Um, they arrived in the morning and then they like did all the, you know, the karaoke, the, uh, the karaoke and then the meet and greet.
And they're like, yeah, I'm flying back after this meet and greet.
I'm like, oh my God.
Oh my God.
Thank you.
I felt bad because.
Like, like majority of the, the, the meet and greet, it was just like me yapping.
And then, and then the staff members like, time's up.
I was like, oh, oh no, I didn't let you talk.
Like, I'm sorry.
I'll just be like, hey, and stuff.
Hey, you're almost done.
And I'm like, oh my God.
What do you want to say?
I'm sorry.
Hey, you're almost done.
But yeah, that was, that was basically, uh, AvCon so far for me.
Um, but yes, it's been, it's been great so far.
Uh, definitely having a lot.
I love doing conventions.
Cause you know, I get to see you guys.
Like I could touch you, like put faces to your names.
And even though like, I'm going to forget your, I'm, I'm not a face person.
I just need you guys to know that like, uh, sometimes I forget faces because I'm, you know, I mean, I'm illiterate as fuck.
But like in the moment I'll get to see, put a face to your name.
No, I've actually like, I've, I've actually forgotten like classmates faces at points too.
Um, because like, uh, I don't know.
I'm just not a face person.
I'm a name person, not a face person.
Like I've, they'll be like, I'll be like, who's that.
And then out.
And I see them as like, I still don't know.
Who it is.
And then they'll say the name and I was like, oh, that guy, I remember him.
So I, I literally can't remember.
I like, I don't know.
I'm very forgetful when it comes to faces.
Okay.
I realized like, we're sort of like very off topic for the first 22 minutes.
Uh, because we're sort of on a tight, a little bit of a tight schedule right now, since we're after this, we had to go straight to the apex shit.
Uh, so behind the scenes of the skin suit reveal.
Um, it was, uh, for the, uh, artists and, um, team, uh, my team that's working on this.
We're wondering, oh, what can I, and cannot post.
Uh, I'll write this in the server.
I know that some of you guys are watching this right now.
Um, basically you guys, even if I don't show the work that you guys gave me, um, also I didn't really, I didn't like save everything.
Yeah.
So I saved everything that are behind the scenes.
Channel, but I didn't say like look back.
I was so busy guys.
I know the wallpapers haven't been posted.
The 3D models haven't been posted.
The music haven't been posted.
Guys I can't wait to like rest one day.
Guys what is resting like again?
There's a lot.
It'll eventually just so you guys know they'll eventually be posted guys.
I swear to God.
I swear to God it will be posted soon.
By the way Minecraft server will be open next week guys.
We are gonna have a I'm gonna make a whitelist in the membership post.
And like I'm gonna have a mod start whitelisting people.
But yes, the Minecraft server is finally finally gonna be up next week after so long.
There was a they actually I think they gave me did they give me a refund?
I was so surprised.
I need to look at that.
Give me a sec.
I need to look this up.
Cuz I think they actually they were like they felt really bad and they're like we're gonna give you a refund.
I was like, oh my god what?
This is like oh, yeah, they're gonna give me a partial refund for The server because they felt they never they had a they were like we're so sorry like we never had to delay a project For this long, so then they gave me a partial refund.
Which version will it be?
A good question.
I'll give you guys the details very soon cuz like they originally they were ready for this week.
They were ready for the Minecraft server this week.
I was like and then I I didn't answer the message for like four days.
We're ready to debut the Minecraft server this Wednesday And then I did not answer the message in four days and they're like poking me and was like hey so like yeah What's going on?
And I'm like, I'm sorry I'm sorry.
I'm so tired I'm so tired
I'm so tired I'm so tired I'm sorry can we do another?
Next week I'm sorry we have to do next week.
This week is it's a lot This week is it's a lot So they're like yeah, we can do next week.
I'm like oh thank god
So so that's why we I'm doing my best.
I am doing my best guys So I think it's awesome cuz like I'm doing everything I would I was able to do in the past but then like I put everything Like like I was like the sooner the better, you know, like I didn't I didn't like what's the word?
I didn't I didn't like stagger stagger things I was just like bam bam bam bam bam and all just jumbled together like everything's just I Remembered like I think like three three or four months ago.
They're like hey, maybe you shouldn't say yes to all these things That's the stuff happening in June and July It's like no I want to do it
But staff team they're like hey dokey, I don't know this seems all really too close together Maybe you should like reject some of these as like no I'm not I'm not I'm not rejecting I never had a chance to do any of these things So I would say yes everything and then and then yeah dokey Yeah,
dokey.
Past dokey really fucked over current dokey
Yeah past dokey really did fuck over current dokey that's for sure I did not pace myself at all Many thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you the day where you get to actually do nothing is the real celebration of the year Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you um um so So that's why there's a lot of things there's so many things happening in June and July because there was a lot of stuff that was offered June for like June to July completion type deal or like like the events will be June to July and then I was like yes And they're like yeah,
but then you have this other thing going on too.
That's like the day after and I'm like it doesn't matter It's virtual.
I'll be there Yes, and then and then And that's why my schedule is like this today
But I'm having fun I'm having fun though in the end even though I am tired a bit Okay, a bit is sort of an understatement, but like I'm enjoying the moment.
You know I'm enjoying the moment and pretty sure when I look back to it.
I'll be like oh my god I was a lot during that week, but like I still have a great time I got to meet my Dragoons and I got to I get to hang out with my dragoons and that's all that matters to me Oh, okay.
Anyway behind the scenes for real uh
For real behind the scenes I need to move myself a little bit so you can see that I got rid of like oh shit Okay, that's not it.
That might be a moving myself a little bit too much Okay, whoa, okay.
Give me a sec.
Whoa, sorry Give me a sec.
I need a adjust some stuff.
I'm gonna okay.
I'm gonna make another version of me real fast Woo, I'm gonna Naruto make another version.
Okay.
I should not be behind the table guys.
I'm sorry bartender I'm not here to steal your your beer and alcohol Sorry bartender.
Let's give me a sec.
I I messed up.
I messed up.
Alright, here we go Alright, this is where I'm supposed to okay.
Anyway, I'm gonna move over here.
So I'm covering like half I'm gonna laugh the chat right now.
You guys are gonna see the chat like between my hair.
I'll be here.
I think that here.
Alright.
Alright, anyway.
So you guys can see the left side where I'm gonna put some behind the scenes stuff.
Um...
Oh, I'm really... I'm tired.
Today is a long day.
Alright.
Okay, so I wanna show you guys.
This debut...
I'm not gonna tell you guys like the price of everything in the public stream.
I finally calculated everything.
Well, I didn't calculate everything.
So like, when you... I do everything via PayPal.
So, the thing is there's like money out in the PayPal.
And even then there's like some stuff that doesn't show up.
Cause you know like...
The...
The skin suit, the rigging and everything.
That was like done...
Like maybe like a couple of months ago.
And uh...
Because of that it doesn't show up.
But then you can see money out.
And then I saw money out.
And I was like...
Oh my god.
And then there's some people that haven't even sent me invoices yet.
I have some people and there's some I haven't paid invoices yet.
And I was like...
Oh my god.
LOL
So...
Don't worry, people.
In that member's stream you'll see how many...
How much it was.
Cause like I'll have a stream and I'll be like trigger warning financial...
Poor financial decisions.
LOL
Because like I said, there was no budget going in.
I was just like, whatever, you guys.
Like, here's a blank check.
Here's a fucking blank check.
Go wild.
And then I realized maybe telling people here's a blank check, go wild, is not the best idea.
Anyway, um...
Okay, so...
This debut has been planned for like two and a half months, I believe.
The reason... It wasn't sooner because like, I had to like, I guess like, figure out some stuff.
And also like, you know, my skin suit wasn't really done done by then.
Um, so there was like a lot of stuff I had to figure out myself.
Like, what I exactly want.
By two and a half months, I sort of finalized like, exactly the idea.
So I'm gonna show you guys like, uh...
My initial prompt.
This is basically like, what I wrote.
Like, the very first thing I, uh...
I wrote to people.
So I was like...
So the whole debut...
Is based off of...
So this is my...
My pitch, basically.
Where...
Uh, the...
What the entire team saw.
And like, what we're building off on.
Um...
So like I said, it's like, basically my...
Yeah.
TLDR.
This is my pitch.
There's more, by the way.
If you guys were like, TLDR...
There's more.
This is basically the...
The pitch I gave to the team.
And to like, the animators and everything.
Of, um...
By the way!
In this pitch, I didn't even include the animation pitch too.
Because I made a separate pitch for the animator.
Because this doesn't include the animation.
This is like, the gaming area.
Of...
Of everything.
So, um...
So like, in this...
This is just a gaming pitch.
Of the like, overlay.
Of the gaming overlay.
Like, Dokiverse and everything.
Um...
And the animation had its own...
Very own...
Uh...
Very own like...
Pitch itself.
That was even...
That was like, also pretty long.
That was like, several paragraphs as well.
So basically, this is how it all started.
Like, I'm not even gonna read this.
Because it is definitely TLDR.
But...
Uh...
I had this idea...
For...
A year.
I've had this idea.
I've always...
I wanted to do this...
For a year.
Um...
So this was like...
Because this was a super duper...
Ambitious...
Project.
Um...
I think the reason why...
I also didn't do this...
I didn't...
I had it on the back burner.
Because I've had like...
Um...
I had like, several ideas...
That I put on back burners.
And then I'll be like...
Do I have the money for this type deal?
Uh...
Hahahaha...
And I...
I was like...
I don't really think I have the funding for this yet.
So I would just put it...
I have like, several ideas that...
That's in my brain.
That's like...
Been in the back burner.
And...
Uh...
And everything.
Um...
So now...
When I finally decided to do this idea...
I was like...
I have enough money...
To like...
Be like...
No budget.
Go wild.
Hahahaha...
Cause like...
I felt like...
This idea...
This...
Um...
This idea that I had...
For it...
Was incredibly ambitious.
And I knew that this would require...
A lot...
A lot of money.
Um...
So...
I never really did it.
I always kept it...
I had like...
I actually had...
A...
Um...
What's the word?
I had a...
Low budget...
Lower budget...
Like an actual budget plan.
To...
For a...
Lower...
I guess like a lower tier version of this.
Like not as...
Not as ambitious.
But like more budget friendly.
Um...
But...
Uh...
It was never actually implemented.
Um...
So I'm happy that...
Now...
I have the money...
And the funding...
To do like the actual full plan.
Of this project.
Um...
Because like I said...
It definitely had...
Uh...
It had a lot of elements playing into it.
It was...
Yeah...
Oh my gosh...
There's so many...
By the way...
This is not related to behind the scenes.
But I wanted to show you guys...
New emotes by the way.
New emotes!
Uh...
I won't be getting these until...
Dokomi is over.
Because the artist is at Dokomi.
At the moment.
So...
New emotes guys!
It's gonna...
Uh...
We're gonna have the emotes...
Like maybe like next week I think.
When the artist...
Um...
Is back from Dokomi.
And uh...
And sends these files to me.
Uh...
My favorite is...
The...
The fifth one.
Uh...
The fifth one is...
Is my favorite so far.
Because we never had the fifth one before.
But...
I was like...
I want to get this.
I want this type of emote.
I want despair.
I want...
Yes.
We're gonna have map again guys.
Um...
Classic map emote.
Where I'm like...
Where the fuck are we guys?
Where...
Where are we?
I don't know where...
I don't know how to read the map.
Where are we?
Also I need to remember to remove the screenshots guys.
Because uh...
I'm so worried my OPS might crash.
Hahaha.
I need to remember to remove...
I need to remember to remove the screenshots.
Instead of dragging it in.
Alright.
Anyway.
Sorry.
I really had to...
I really wanted to show that to you guys.
Because...
Um...
Before...
Uh...
We go to real behind the scenes.
Oh my god.
30 minutes has already passed.
And we haven't really went to behind the scenes.
I'm so sorry.
I just...
I just want to talk to you guys.
Chat.
I just wanted to talk to you guys.
Hahaha.
I can't help yapping.
Um...
What else did I want to say?
Shit.
Okay.
Sorry.
There was like something else I really want to talk about.
Before we actually get into the...
Uh...
The meat of things.
Fuck.
What was it?
Hahaha.
I'm trying to...
I'm trying to remember right now.
Fuck.
What was it?
Oh shit.
Sorry guys.
I need to check in.
Checking in.
Okay.
Sorry.
Alright.
Uh...
Sorry.
I had to check in with the quads thing.
Um...
Oh my gosh.
Sorry.
I need to remember.
I need to remember what it is I wanted to talk about regarding emotes.
What the fuck was it?
What?
Hahaha.
I actually did write some notes down.
Oh my god.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Oh yes.
Yes.
Intro will be done soon.
Intro.
New intro.
I'm going to give you guys a sneak peek to the new intro.
Okay.
I didn't save it but don't worry.
I am a bug.
Oh!
Anime emotes!
I'm so happy because I'm going to be working with the person who did my old animated emotes.
So if you guys remember the classic anime emotes that we had.
It's going to be animated by the same person.
I was really happy because I found the Twitter and it was last known activity a year ago.
I was like, where did he go?
Hahaha.
Wait.
I was just like, where did he go?
So I had like backup.
I was like researching backup animators for emotes.
And I had like five tabs.
I had five tabs open of their Twitter.
Twitter and stuff.
And then I think like two days ago they were like, oh yeah.
Oh yeah.
Because like I like DM them and I had their Discord.
Like I remember their Discord username.
So then I like added them on Discord.
I was like, oh yeah.
I was like, are you, are you alive?
Hahaha.
And they were like, yeah.
Like I could still add, I can animate your, I would love to animate your emotes again.
Like, but like, are you okay with, we can't do it.
We still have some people we have to animate for and like, I'm not doing it full time anymore.
But like, are you okay with waiting?
I'm like, yeah, I'm okay with waiting.
Because I really liked how they...
Hahaha.
I really loved their, their animation.
I really loved their animation.
If you guys remember how the monkey looked like before, like it's honestly one of my favorite animated emotes.
So, and also, oh, the cheer too.
The cheer was really pretty.
So I was really happy that, you know, they're still alive on the internet.
And it might be a while before we're going to get animated emotes back again.
But like, I'm just happy that, you know, they're still around.
I'm just happy they're still, they're still around.
I don't know.
Cause it's like...
You know, it's like, oh man, when you find the person you like working with and you just, you don't want to work with someone different because you're so used to working with them.
Um, boy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
If I make a cardboard cutout of Doki, should I call her Doki board?
Honestly, it looks pretty swaad.
But yes, it'll be really cool though.
If you make a Doki cutout.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um, but yes, anyway, as I was saying, okay, let me grab the, uh, let me, uh, grab the, uh, the, uh, okay, I need to download.
Download time.
All right.
I don't know if there's audio.
If there's audio, that'd be awkward.
But yes, here's, here you go.
Here's a sneak peek of the new intro.
Um, they'll be done, I think like by the end of the month.
Uh, yeah.
Oh shit.
I'm sorry if it's loud.
Uh, I think it's this.
Yeah.
We'll loop it.
Dad is here.
Yeah.
Dad's gonna be here.
Um, but yes, uh, this is a sneak peek of the new intro.
I decided to have both dad and you guys there with me.
Cause they were at first, they were just, they removed the Dragoon.
And I was like, no, the Dragoon will be with us.
So whenever that's done, we'll be, uh, whenever.
The reason why it took so long was that we were trying to figure out the background.
Um, like there was a lot of like background possibilities, but honestly I did not like any of the newer backgrounds.
And, um, I feel really bad cause I made the animator go through like lots and lots of variations for the background.
So like here was some of them, by the way, this is not just the only, uh, the only background.
That they sent me.
And I honestly, I honestly thought out of all of them, the original background color, uh, with the old skin suit, uh, looked the best overall.
Because, um, because like, um, I wanted to make sure like everybody popped out.
So like, I know some of you are like, oh, but I looked six, like six though.
But like dad blends into six way too much.
So, um, and also like we try to play around with three and four and, um, it was just not, it did not look as appealing as I would have liked.
Um, that's why, that's why I went with, uh, went with seven.
I went, I kept the classic because like I understand like six, I and the Dragoon pop up a lot.
But dad blended in way too much.
So I was like, uh, gotta go.
So and seven and the classic one, everybody, um, everybody looked good.
Ha-hahaha.
I want to make sure that everybody is good.
Um, that's why that's why I was like, uh, that's why, uh, it took a while.
It took, they were, this could have been ready, like the day after debut.
But then I was like, background color.
Heheheh.
Lalala.
LOL.
Alright, background colors!
And then we played around with background colors for so long.
And then I was like, I'm sorry.
I just like the original.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry for making you do so many background colors.
Richu, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
All for bad financial decisions.
Love new skin suit.
The flesh bang is my favorite.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
I think my favorite is just how fluid everything... I'm just so not used to it.
I'm so not used to how fluid the rigging is, honestly.
It's actually crazy.
It's so...
Oh my gosh.
It's insane.
I'm so used to barely moving.
It is...
It's actually...
Like I can't...
Sometimes I just can't stop looking at myself because I was like, damn.
Fuck, I'm hot.
Alright, anyway.
Actual!
Sorry.
Now we're at the real...
I'm so sorry.
We're at the real...
Behind the scenes.
So there was one thing that I really wanted to show you guys.
I'm gonna see if I can find...
Where I saved it.
Okay, it's a mess.
A lot of this stuff is like super messy right now because I just...
Just like right-click saved everything.
So I'm gonna see if I can find this concept art that I really, really wanted to show you guys.
Because this concept art...
I...
I don't know if you guys remember it.
But...
Uh...
There was a concept art where...
Where I showed you guys a tomato.
Uh...
Do you guys...
Do you guys remember that?
Yes,
do you guys remember the...
Uh...
The tomato from...
That I showed?
And I was like, I love this.
This tomato shit is like my favorite thing so far.
Um...
That tomato was actually concept art for...
Uh...
One of the sketches that it was supposed to be.
We had a lot of concept sketches regarding like the splash art.
And it sucked because honestly it was like one of the hardest decisions to make.
And because the splash...
We had so many splash screen alternatives.
It was actually...
Um...
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna try to find it right now.
I'm trying to find...
Okay, here it is.
Oh yeah, this is from Kleia.
So...
Okay.
Okay, so...
I'm sorry.
I'm looking at it.
Do you guys see a familiar face right here?
Okay.
Anyway.
So the tomato actually came from...
From that splash art.
Um...
And that's why I was like, guys, I love this.
I wish there was so many choices.
There was one where we ride a dragon.
It was so good.
It was so difficult.
Guys, this has to be like one of the most difficult...
Uh...
Choice.
Like I went with three.
Because the reason why...
Like...
Okay.
So...
Um...
Uh...
For this concept art...
Um...
I had to make sure that...
For this concept art...
For this thing is...
The concept art has a lot of varieties going in.
And so...
I wanted to make sure like each cons...
Each splash art...
Each splash art is a different theme.
So we were...
Had already had like a splash art dedicated to...
Uh...
The new look.
Which was like the fire.
The fire in the background.
And then we had one that was dedicated to the tomato.
Like the one where like you were holding the tomato.
And then we had one of the...
We had a shooting one scene.
And then we had like another like relaxing scene.
So I thought...
So in the end we picked three.
Because it was like something we didn't have.
We didn't have like a...
Alt Doki scene yet.
And we didn't have like a concert.
Like you know like maybe like a concert.
Uh...
Patch.
The cosmetic.
So...
Um...
And there wasn't all...
Yeah there was one with all the dragoons and everything.
So it was really difficult because...
We had so many different...
We had...
I needed to make sure...
Um...
There was a lot of variations...
Of the splash art.
Because like...
Oh my gosh.
All of these look amazing.
But we already had a lot of concepts with the other four.
And I was like...
Okay we didn't have a concert scene yet.
So that's why I picked three.
But oh my god.
Okay.
But yes.
That is where the tomato comes from.
Like the...
The...
The tomato right?
Yeah.
So...
I wish we went with one just for the tomato.
But...
I think one was my favorite when it came to like...
Um...
Just for that face.
That was my favorite.
Alright so...
This is another concept we had.
Um...
So this one.
This one was also...
Um...
Another for the splash art.
As you see we got B2.
B2 was the one we ended up with in the end.
Um...
So that was like B1.
B...
I thought it would be B2.
I picked...
A2 and B2.
I didn't pick A1.
Like I said we already had the concept art with...
Uh...
We already had the splash art with like...
Alt.
Girl.
Doki.
With...
Uh...
The concert.
And then we had A3.
I didn't choose A3 because we already had one where like there's a shooting scene for A3.
So that was like either A2 or B2.
And then...
We went with B2 in the end because like I said, we wanted a little teaser for when the patch goes live.
And then the teaser in the background and stuff like that.
There were so... I told you guys, there were so many concepts that we ended up not doing.
Because all the artists, they would draw a bunch of concepts all together.
And then we had to pick one because there was just enough time for one or two if we're lucky.
One or two for the splash art.
And it's one of the hardest decisions to make, honestly.
I think this was like... the splash art was like the hardest decision to make.
Because I had to make sure everything was like balanced well.
And like there's like enough... like there's enough variations to stuff.
Alright, here's another one that I'll show you guys.
Like I think we had like so many artists in splash art.
So I have so many to show.
So here's another... here's some other concepts that we have.
Oh my gosh.
One was so good.
So we had all of these.
They were all really, really...
Like I said, they were all so good.
It was so difficult to pick.
We went with five in the end because we didn't have anything related with the tomato yet.
So we went with five because...
Because we were like, okay, we should...
We should get something related to tomato.
Because it makes sense.
And then I didn't want to do six because I was like, okay, so the anime trailer...
The anime trailer had already had like something to do with cowboy tomato.
So and then... and obviously a lot of them were pretty funny.
But what is something more peaceful?
Because we had a lot of funny... we had some funny ones going in.
So I was like, okay, we're going to go with five because it's like a peaceful...
Like it's different.
It's peaceful.
And...
And everything.
I didn't want to do anything that really revealed what I...
What I was going to look like.
So that's why we scrapped...
Despite seven and eight looking really fucking cool.
It's going to spoil like parts of the outfit.
Or like parts of the skin suit.
So we didn't do seven or eight.
It was... I think I chose like one, six.
Yeah, I remember it was like one, six or five.
And then we settled with five.
But yes.
The decisions I had to make was very, very difficult.
Let's see.
Sorry, Heaven.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Real talk.
Could we like crowdfund a full version of A2 or something?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Maybe in the future.
I won't mind like making a community post on maybe like members or...
Maybe like members because it's going to be a members wallpaper.
I mean, well, if you guys want these as wallpapers.
Because wallpapers are going to be like members.
Like the ones that in this, in this, they're not members.
They're all going to be free.
The splash art, the ones that got made into actual splash art will be available for free for everybody.
But if you do guys want some of these concept arts turned into actual wallpapers, I might ask in the members.
Like in like post all these concepts and ask you guys which one you guys want to like make into like members wallpapers in the future.
Because that's actually a good idea.
Because that's actually a really good idea.
But yes, this is another one.
Let me see.
There was like a couple or so many guys.
I had to make a lot of decisions.
Let's see.
All right.
There's this one.
And then did I show this one?
No, I didn't show this one yet.
And then I got to make sure I close my tabs.
Because while I was saving.
I just need you guys to know.
While I was saving behind the scenes images.
I blue screen because I didn't close any of my tabs.
So I need to remind myself to close tabs.
So I do not blue screen.
Because that would be very awkward.
Um.
I'm trying to remember.
Okay.
I know.
All right.
I know there was a lot of concepts from this artist.
Because we did not pick the other concept.
We did not pick some of the other ones that they first sent.
So I'm trying to make sure I find the right one.
I'm trying to make sure.
Oh, there were these.
Okay.
All right.
So I need you guys to know.
The first name that we came up with was...
Oh, this one.
Okay.
As you guys can see.
Oh, there were so many good concepts.
This was like one of the first concept arts we received.
Oh, but there were so many.
There were...
We had a lot of really, really good ideas here.
So I think you guys can see that we went with one.
Because we wanted an action scene.
You see two.
Two was the inspiration behind.
I really...
I loved...
I loved two a lot.
Two was actually also one of my favorites.
That was given to Nico to do in the end.
Because we had so many concepts that were really, really, really good.
That like another artist took two to draw.
For their own splash art.
And that's where the, you know, the bar scene was inspired by.
Because I thought it was like, oh my god, that's actually so clever.
That was really, really clever.
So that's...
So huge shout out to Xtrident for coming with all these concepts.
Because that's where I got my inspiration for the background itself as well.
But yes.
The original game title was going to be Flock Champs.
That came...
That was came up by the team.
I was like, no.
I just thought it didn't roll off the tongue well.
Like, you know, Flock Champs.
It just...
It felt awkward like saying it.
So then that's why I stole your ideas, Dragones.
So I really appreciate you guys.
I stole Dokiiverse and Battlebirds from you guys in the memberships.
Because I was like, hey guys.
I'm gonna...
I need an idea for a game title.
Because like...
I'm gonna be making a wallpaper themed around...
I mean, technically I wasn't wrong.
There are wallpapers.
So...
So I was like, hey guys.
I need some game ideas.
And then I think like there was one.
Someone said Dokiiverse.
And then another one was Flock Champs.
Not Flock Champs.
Sorry.
Flock Champs was the one we rejected.
And then one said Battlebirds.
And Battlebirds was like the most upvoted...
Updudes going in.
So I was like, alright.
We're gonna...
I'm gonna steal that.
And then be like, hey guys.
I came up with...
No.
Okay.
I didn't say that to the others.
Like, hey guys.
So I asked the members.
I think we're gonna go with these.
These names.
Anyway.
So these are the concept art.
Four looked really good.
Four looked like in Apex Legends.
Like opening.
Cause like originally for the devs.
It was gonna be just like normal Doki Bird productions.
But then we saw Doki Verse.
And then we're like, oh Doki Verse will work so well.
It's gonna work so well as like a...
Like a, you know, a game publishing company.
A publisher name.
So then that's why we stole...
We borrowed.
It was...
You guys posted on my channel.
So it's my idea.
You know that's like...
You know like that's TOS shit.
Like if you post it on our website.
It's ours now.
Because you willingly posted on the website.
You know that rule that some companies have.
To like legally.
They're like it's not yours.
It's ours now.
It's like how...
Oh my god.
I think I remember.
That's why like Deviantart lowkey died.
Because Deviantart released a new TOS.
Being like.
If you post this on our website.
On Deviantart.
It's now legally.
We can use it for anything we want.
Because you posted it on our website.
So like technically.
If you post...
Because you commented willingly on my community post.
It's mine now.
I'm gonna kill you.
No I'm joking.
Guys I'm joking.
I'm joking.
It's our idea.
Okay.
It's not mine.
It's ours.
But yes.
Here were all the concepts.
For...
From X Trident.
Like it's so difficult.
There were so many.
Really.
Really good ideas.
That.
Is very difficult to be like.
Which one is the.
Because they could only do.
Like every.
I think almost all the artists.
I think every artist.
Yeah.
Every artist could only do one.
And because they can only do one.
It was a very difficult decision.
That.
Yeah.
Pick one.
They are all so good.
I had to make one decision.
Let's see.
So we have.
I gotta check this out.
It's aLED?
super chat.
Thank you.
Finally got my two Doki keychains.
I hung one on the mirror of my car.
I was surprised by the amount of import taxes it so.
What?
20 Euros?
God damn taxes.
Where are they fun?
What are they making anyway?
If I can still fucking live on Mars.
What's the point of paying taxes?!
Don't.
Please don't audit me.
I pay my taxes.
Please don't.
It was a joke Canadian government.
Please don't audit me.
I do pay my taxes!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So you're saying that we reply with sussy things?
No, I can pick and choose.
I can pick and choose what is ours.
Thank you for the super chat, Kaz.
Thank you, thank you.
For legal reasons, that was a joke Canadian government.
And if the American government is watching...
I'm happy I'm not in America or part of a country that's part of the European Union.
Is that too much of a low blow?
You'll understand if you're part of the European Union.
She knows!
Let's see.
You know, Canadian taxes fucking suck as well.
Canadian fucking post to serve.
It's okay, you know what's fucked up?
So it's like, I live in a country that's part of the European Union.
Sad face.
Okay, you know what fucking sucks?
Canadian business owners will understand.
It is more expensive to ship within Canada than it is to ship in Canada.
Like, ship out to America.
Like what kind of bull...
We live in the same country!
What bullshit is that?
It is!
It's actually...
Yes, if you're shipping parcels in Canada...
Letters don't count, by the way.
And we're not talking about letters.
But like if you're using like...
If you're shipping like parcels and stuff...
It's more expensive.
To ship within the country.
It's bullshit!
Like why?
Like, what do you mean?
I don't...
I don't understand.
I actually don't understand the Canadian...
Like support post offices.
But please make it make sense.
Like...
Oh my God.
I don't understand.
Like Canada, please.
I don't...
How...
Why do we do this?
Okay.
Um...
Andy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's not like we're fucking traveling mountains all the time.
It's not like we're like fucking...
It's not like...
We don't have cars.
Like...
Yeah.
Oh my God.
And then...
Oh...
The user post office!
Guys...
Dokie Merch is helping...
Dokie Merch is funding the Canadian healthcare system right now.
If you are a Canadian Dragoon and you're like...
Why the fuck is it so expensive to ship within Canada?
I...
I want you to know that I'm helping funding...
I'm helping to fund...
We're funding the healthcare system!
...together.
You're buying stuff from my store?
I have to pay... you're paying the shipping and I have to pay the taxes too?
We're funding the Canadian healthcare system together.
Oh my god.
It's actually crazy.
I don't understand.
Every time I see the shipping to America versus shipping in Canada.
And then the thing is... I don't understand.
You United States dragoons, when you're shipping in the United States, it's cheaper.
But when you're shipping to Canada, they add $20.
Like a small fucking item you buy in America as a Canadian dragoon.
And you guys, you compared to shipping in the United States versus shipping to Canada.
It's like $20 extra.
But we live next door!
We live next door!
And it's cheaper for us to ship to you!
So should it be the same?
I'm sorry, I'm just really mad.
That shit pisses me off.
If it's gonna be expensive in Canada, why can't it be expensive in America?
Considering a trade-off for the healthcare.
No name.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't understand.
I'll never understand.
Lord Crow says thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's a freedom tax.
Every American knows about it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I got somebody who was like, it's often cheaper to ship to the US and drive down to Canada.
Yeah, you fucking ship it to the closest city in America that's closest to you.
And then you drive down to the border to pick it up because you don't want to pay $20 in Canadian shipping.
I'm sorry.
I got sidetracked there.
I got really, really passionate about this topic because I...
Guys, I know like being Canadian, maybe it looks great, but it's...
There's a little thing that just make it not so much fun.
It's just... I just feel like it's a highway robbery because the Canadian dollar sucks compared to the American dollar.
But yet you guys get cheaper shipping.
Like what's the point?
Our Canadian dollar sucks shit compared to the American dollar.
But yet somehow we have to pay more to ship within our own country?
Make it make sense.
Alright, I'm done.
I'm sorry.
I'm really... I'm...
I'm really passionate about this topic because...
Because when I first found out about it, when we were like dealing with the store and then...
And then like I was like looking at the shipping prices.
Because we were fixing the shipping stuff.
And...
I was like adding my staff team was like, why is it like this?
And then they're like, it's supposed to be like this.
I was like, that doesn't make sense.
Because like at first, okay, the thing is like at first we had like American staff member that's handling the store stuff.
And then they were even they were like, I don't understand.
I don't understand.
Why is the Canadian shipping more expensive than the American shipping?
And then I was like, that's what I was thinking.
And then...
Because like we were printing out the labels and stuff.
And we had like a scale of it.
We had all the products.
So we're starting to print out the labels.
And then we're like, wait, we fucked up the shipping prices because apparently we priced Canadian shipping lower than American shipping at first.
But we think everything's fixed now, by the way, all the shipping prices.
And then so now we had we later on, we had to go back to the shipping.
Later on, we had a Canadian.
Our distributor is from Canada.
And they took over the shop.
So the distributor was going through it and was like, no, that's that's how it works.
Like in Canada, it's just more expensive to ship within your own country.
That's like, why?
And then the American staff member was like, that doesn't make sense.
And then and then and then our Canadian distributor was like, no, no, it's just like that.
And I was like, that's what I was saying.
It doesn't make sense.
And she was like, no, it's just like that.
That's that's how it is.
Oh, my God.
OK, sorry.
Back to the concept.
All right.
I'm sorry.
I went like 20 minutes on this.
This is something I'm very passionate about.
It's just it's just something I'm incredibly passionate about.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry to the team.
Anyway, here's some more concept art.
This artist actually did the...
I think it was the one with the fire behind.
But they sent us extra concept art.
I decided not to do this because it overlapped with...
It overlapped with like, tried to do this.
Trident's initial idea regarding the shooting guns thing.
So that's why we decided not to go with any of these concept art.
Because it overlapped already with Trident's pitch.
Um, so we went with the one with the dragoons and the fire in the back.
Oh, my God.
It's so weird to just jump back into talking about this.
After being like incredibly passionate.
Alright, billboard concept art.
Billboard concept art.
This one was fun because the billboard stuff was decided sort of like at the last minute type deal.
Not like last last minute.
But like after when we were building up the 3D set.
We realized we wanted to add billboards.
So this was like the original.
Please don't demonetize me, YouTube.
But this was like one of the original.
Hahaha.
One of the original...
We have more concept art for splash art.
But like I didn't...
I have to scroll to find it by the way.
So I'm just going by with like what I have so far.
Um...
This was like the one of the original concepts.
So we're like...
We want to do something as a parody of gamer subs.
So like we had dad subs.
And then later on...
Here are the...
Oh, my God.
This is a big file.
We had like the other...
Uh...
Hahaha.
Okay.
I love the...
We almost went with 2B by the way.
We almost...
We almost went with 2B.
Because I thought 2B and 2C was really good.
Um...
But these were some of the concepts.
Uh...
Regarding...
Regarding the billboards and stuff.
So we had like stuff with...
At first it wasn't going to be dad subs.
It was going to be some fucking energy drink.
Uh...
We almost went with 2B and 2C.
And then we were like...
Wait.
We should do a parody of gamer subs.
It's going to make more sense.
You know?
With gamer subs instead.
Um...
So here are some of our billboard concepts.
I think this was also billboard...
Yes.
This was...
Hahaha.
Okay.
Some of them are...
Hahaha.
I forgot about what some of them looked like.
So looking at it again is pretty funny.
Uh...
Alright.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
At least this tip is more for you than it.
Comment below.
Also desktop, YouTube, not liking PayPal for some fucking reason.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
I was slurping my slushy.
My mango slushy.
Uh...
But yes.
This was...
Uh...
This was more concept art regarding dad subs and some of the billboard designs for it.
And then we had...
We had...
They had...
They made concept art for the billboard.
Concept art.
Uh...
The flavors.
The branding of dad subs.
Oh, you guys look so fucking stupid.
Hahaha.
Um...
Gary, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
God, this country shipping cost sucks.
Anyway, here's the next concept.
Alright.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
What else do I have?
What else?
Uh...
I'm trying to find the other...
Oh yes.
Here are some...
Oh yeah.
Here you go.
Here's like the billboard by the way.
Uh...
We're...
You guys are wondering when is the VR chat gonna be out, um, in public?
Um...
The...
We...
We are currently post...
Not postponing.
But I am letting the 3D team have a little break at the moment.
I'm letting my entire team have a little break before we go back into work mode.
Because it was two and a half months of like...
Work almost every day for everybody.
Like they had meetings.
They actually had like...
Staff meetings and stuff to like talk, discuss and build off of everything.
And like...
Like set design and design the entire concept.
So like I'm...
Cause like I...
I actually had one of the team members be like, so when are we doing the VR chat world?
Like when are we joining the server?
And I was like, oh I'm making the server now but everybody's gonna have a little break at the moment before...
Um...
Before we go back into actually doing stuff for this.
Because there's obviously like...
I want to add more to just the world.
I want to have like little fun games in there if possible.
And maybe flesh out the place a little bit more.
Like build off like...
How did we get here?
Like could we do something where we...
Um...
When we spawn in there's a little area to spawn in.
Like a respawn point.
You know like in Team Fortress 2?
There's like a respawn locker.
Or like in Overwatch there's like a place for you to respawn at.
So I want to like...
Add more lore and lore building to...
This is...
I know like in the game you drop down and stuff.
But like obviously in VRChat you can't do that.
Or maybe like...
Actually another idea I have is just...
You spawn in like a room and you can click something there.
And then you drop down.
I wonder if you can do that.
That would be cool.
Like um...
You spawn in like a lobby-esque area.
And then like you click a button.
And then you like click a Q or something.
And then you like...
You drop down into the world.
That would be... I think that's it.
I think that would be really fun to do.
Like there's like character selection in the respawn.
Like the spot.
Like the selection room and stuff.
It's like...
I don't know if you guys ever know this classic VRChat world.
That was based off of Sword Art Online.
I remember being like incredibly stupid because...
Um...
It was like...
Oh!
A VRChat world that is like...
Um...
That is basically a replica of Sword Art Online.
And then you drop into this room.
This like...
Somebody's room.
And then I remember I was so stupid.
Because I was like...
What the fuck?
Where's the Sword Art Online room?
Like...
The background looks like a forest.
And there's a castle and everything.
And then...
Apparently you're supposed to click on a PC in that world.
And then you get dropped into the Sword Art Online world.
But I didn't know that.
I was so confused.
I was just like...
Um...
I was like...
What do you mean?
Like...
Why is it just this person's room?
This random guy's room?
Where is it?
What is the world?
By the way, I've never watched Sword Art Online.
So like...
All I know about it are the memes.
I just thought it was cool.
I wanted to look at it.
Anyway, I figured that out like...
Two years later.
When another friend of mine was like...
Yo, let's go to that Sword Art Online world.
They updated it.
I was like...
What?
Wait, that world?
Wait...
There's more to it than the room?
There's more to it than the fucking room?
Um...
Anyway...
So I was like...
I think that would be a really cool idea.
To be able to like...
You spawn into something outside of that.
But then you can click a button to be dropped down into the gaming world of the area.
So yeah.
Like I said...
It's not gonna be something that's gonna be done right away.
Like even though we have majority of this stuff.
Like...
It's technically finished.
Uh...
We still...
There's a lot of like...
Stuff I want to do to like...
Just build off of the world.
Alright.
So here are some concept arts by the way.
Um...
Like I said...
We had to figure out a lot.
I don't remember what this is.
I think it was just set dressing.
Like...
We had so many cons...
Like some of the things I'm like...
Wait, what is this?
But...
Oh, I remember this.
So we had like...
Loop boxes too.
Like what the...
How the loop box is gonna...
Like the loop box system was gonna work and stuff.
So there's the...
Um...
What was the loop box?
And then one is like...
Uh...
What is like...
Loot crates in the game itself.
So like you know when you're opening the loop box.
Like these were the concept art.
Uh...
So it's like a carton and stuff.
But yeah, we went with the blue.
Because obviously that looks the best.
So...
Some of the concept art for this.
Oh my god.
There were some 3D models that we weren't able to get.
So this is one.
This was...
Uh...
Nice wigs.
Dragoon.
So there were so many.
There was...
I don't know if we used this one.
Because there were so many.
We had some deleted scenes and stuff.
So...
And we had like...
We couldn't add everything.
But this was...
I love the mustache.
The mustache was so good.
Um...
And then we have...
Uh...
Here...
Here's...
Here's Axa's...
Uh...
Dragoon...
Dragoonify.
Dragoon's your Oshi.
No!
My Oshi!
My Oshi's a gooner!
Um...
Oh yeah.
I showed...
Um...
Tempo apparently was asking me for the files.
Because he wants to make it into a plushie.
Like...
Uh...
For himself.
Like...
He wants...
He was like...
Oh my god.
It's so cute.
It's so cool.
Can I have the files so I can make it into a plushie?
He was like...
No problem, man.
Bro, fucking do whatever the fuck you want.
These are...
Because like...
I'm not using it for anything else other than like...
Just for the sake of the reveal.
So it's like...
It was just gonna rot.
Like...
It was like...
Nothing that was gonna be like...
Done with these models.
Other than the fact...
Because I'm not gonna...
You know...
It's...
It's their identity.
It's their property.
Like...
It's their likeness.
It's like their identity.
It's gonna be the same thing that it's gonna be, you know...
Like the sake of like the debut reveal.
Like the debut reveal.
So I was like...
If you guys...
Like I know like Fillion actually reached out to me and asked for like the sticker.
Because she wanted to make it into like her own discord emu.
Because I wasn't gonna sell the sticker.
It was like just made for the sake of the reveal.
Like all this stuff that was based off of like my friends and people I collabed with and everything.
It was just for the sake of the reveal and like...
Like...
Oh my god.
I recognized him!
I'm not gonna make money off of it.
I'm not gonna give it away because it's your likeness.
But if you guys want it, just ask me and I'll hand it over to you guys.
But yes, there's stuff like that.
What else?
Here's some concept art of the logos and stuff.
So this is what it could have...
As you see, I settled with...
Oh my god, making decisions on the look of and aesthetic of things.
So difficult.
Honestly, it's actually such a difficult decision.
Yes, so here's some concept art of the logo and stuff.
And then I think I asked for like parody logos.
I don't remember.
I think like me and someone else in the team were asking for like...
Oh yeah, we should have like parody logos and stuff.
So there's like some...
We were like basing off like some...
Like making parodies off of other games and stuff to make it look real.
To make Dokiverse like a real Battle.net slash Steam.
Like I was like, I needed to...
I need the lore.
I need the lore building.
Everything must feel like it could possibly be an actual game client.
With games on it.
Yes, there's...
Someone's like, oh, what about Duck by Daylight?
I do have that right here.
There was like other...
Oh my god, I need to find it.
But there's like concept art for like...
Like scrapped game logos.
Let's see.
Where is it?
Did I see?
Oh, there it is.
Here's...
This is a horror game.
Oh, there's...
Yeah, there's...
There's basically a Dead by Daylight...
Dead by Daylight...
Was it parody?
And then we had...
Oh my gosh.
Yes, there's so many.
There's so many.
And then...
Oh, so here's a full res of the poster, by the way.
This poster that was there.
We had so many little art stuff that was there.
That's like if you blink, you'll miss it.
So this poster was on the animation.
That was the animation in the beginning.
With the little dragoon.
Like in the backboard.
There's like little stuff in the backboard and everything.
So it was like little small art stuff.
Like little small moments and Easter eggs.
And we're like, if you blink, you would not see this.
So we had this poster made.
Oh my, this other thing.
I specifically requested it.
This other thing.
Let me see if I can find where I saved.
Where did I save it?
I did not save any of this.
This one.
I specifically...
This was right after...
Right after the rest stream.
I was like, I need a book dedicated to the Blood God.
I was like, at the team.
I need...
I need somebody...
Because they're like, what kind of Easter eggs do you want?
And I was like, add a book about the Blood God.
So this is like something that we added in like, retroactively.
Because we were like, what kind of reference do we need?
Also, here's a goon with gun.
Here's a goon with guns.
Also, we had...
Oh my gosh.
I wish you guys could have seen the details of the death box.
This is the death box.
I love the little details.
I wish...
I think like, you guys will be able to see it in the VR chat world.
If you guys...
Whenever it's out.
But there's like, so many little details with the 3D modeling and everything.
It's like, you know...
Oh my gosh.
The little like, little ghost goon there.
Little wisp goon right there.
And then we had like, gun concepts too.
Of everything.
Because we didn't want to like, replicate exactly the wingman.
But like, we had, you know...
It's like a parody.
A parody of the gun.
And stuff like that.
And then like...
We built all the models.
By the way.
All the models in the...
In Dadwood Canyon.
Made from scratch.
Nothing was...
We didn't buy anything from the Unity store.
We didn't like, you know...
Take any of the models that were already pre-made.
All of these models were 100% made from scratch.
So we own the models.
And everything.
And so like...
Because you know...
It's ours.
We didn't buy anything from the Unity store.
It was literally made from scratch.
I think this one...
Okay, what I'm going to show you has to be one of my favorite models.
Because it's so cute.
Look at these cactuses.
I'm sorry, but look at these cactuses.
They're so cute.
It's one of my favorite.
I don't know.
It's just...
Look, it's just so cute.
I don't know.
I just can't help it.
I need you guys to see the cactuses.
They're so fucking cute.
I can't help it.
Sorry.
It's just so cute.
So adorable!
Also some concepts, some 3D model concepts of like our version of the Nessie, the the legally distinct Nessie plushie with Longoon.
So they're like the Longoon model plushie.
And then we will have like it rendered.
I don't know if I saved the rendered version.
No!
Wait, I did.
So it ended up looking like this and then it came into... So a Goonie.
Yeah.
A little Goonie.
What other stuff do I have?
Oh yeah, here's like a map too.
I'll give you guys like 3D shots of the map because it's actually... it's actually crazy like that all of this was made from scratch.
Like oh my god!
Like seeing it all together.
Like all of this being made... like an entire actual world being made in scratch by our 3D team...like holy shit!
Like look at... it looks like an actual map!
Because it happens so fast so you don't like take in the fact that a lot of this there's like stuff on the in the water and everything and in 2.5 months too.
Like, Like in 2.5 months, so...
There's so many things everywhere.
That was just like...
This is like the zoom out.
When you zoom out, you realize, okay, that's not a lot.
But when you zoom in, you're like, whoa!
Holy shit!
That is a lot of stuff going on.
Oh, and then one of my...
staff member was like, where are they dropping?
Staff member...
One of the teams, sorry, not staff member.
One of the debut team, project team, made this and was like, alright guys, where are they...
What POI are they landing?
I thought...
That's so funny.
Where is TSM gonna land?
I thought that was so fucking clever.
I thought that was so silly.
If BattleBirds was an esport, what is their POI?
I don't know.
Oh yeah, here.
And then we had...
Did I show this one already?
Oh yeah, I didn't show this one.
But here's a better picture of DadSubs.
Okay, I'm gonna use the bathroom real quick.
I'll be right back.
You guys can talk amongst yourselves for a little bit.
Give me a sec.
I'll be right back.
Alright, I'm back.
Back from the bathroom break.
Okay.
Let me see.
Let me go in order now of... Oh wait, let's see.
What team am I on?
Alright, QuadShack.
First set of teams for King's Cat.
Okay, what team am I on?
Alright guys, where am I?
I am with...
Poor... What?
Sorry.
Okay.
It's okay.
They won't be watching this so they won't know I hooed them.
Alright.
Okay.
So each game is going...
Each game is going to be randomized.
Each game is gonna be randomized.
So we're gonna be with different people each time.
Anyways, so...
Um...
Okay.
I recognize... Okay, so I recognize the first one.
The first one is dropped.
I recognize him.
I did not hooed dropped.
I hooed the two other players cause I don't know.
I'm not familiar with them.
Oh my god, they did put me as the lowest rank.
Yes!
It's like P1, P2, P3, and P4.
It's marked by like um... how good these people are.
How good these people are at Apex.
And I wrote in the sign up form.
I was like I am... They were like, what's the highest rank you got?
And I was like, diamond.
Cause I was like...
So they put me at P4 which is like the people who are the lowest ranked.
Guys, look.
All the other...
Guys, all the other D... the P4s they play this game regularly.
Okay?
Um...
Anyway.
Anyway, so uh... it's not lying.
It's omitting information.
I'm currently... last two seasons ago, I was diamond.
Two seasons ago, I was diamond.
It's omitting...
It's omitting information.
Um... Anyway.
It's like dropped Melanie par-ray-dol-ly-avoid.
par-ray-dol-ly-avoid.
Yes, I know.
I... Even I'm like...
I'm sorry.
It's okay.
They won't watch this VOD.
Cause it's like they think it's behind the scenes.
Um...
I know dropped!
Dropped's on my team!
This is game one.
Um... And then...
And then there's me.
And then there's me after that.
Um... Team 15 has three players.
Like how are they gonna play?
Like the other...
Okay, you can't say like you're smurfing because like...
Isn't Deridium...
Deridium's literally like Pred.
Like why...
I recognize one person in P4.
And that guy's Pred, isn't he?
He lied even more.
Right?
I mean...
He...
He lied even more!
He's a recent Pred.
Um... Raspberry, thank you.
Welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Um...
I remember I recognized Deridium.
I recognized Deridium being like an actual good player.
I don't recognize anybody else.
But I recognized Deridium.
Um...
Anyway...
Thank god they put me at P4.
Yeah!
P1 is where all the good players are.
Like the actual professional players.
And then like...
And then it goes down from there.
Okay, sorry.
We gotta go back to the... I had to figure out like who... How many games is this?
How many did I accidentally sign up for?
Um...
Six games?
Oh my...
Oh my god, it's six games!
Six!
Okay, we can do this guys.
We can... We can do this!
Okay!
Guys, I figured out I don't read.
I... Guys!
Oh my god!
I don't read, guys!
Okay...
Um...
Wait, is it like... Okay...
First set of teams for... Oh, so like...
Post the next troop during...
Oh!
So like we're gonna be with this team for two games.
Okay.
Sorry, every map is a new team.
JK.
It's not every game is a new team.
Every map is a new team.
Um...
Alright, anyway.
Let's... Let's go through... Sorry, let me actually...
Let me go through it for...
I keep getting distracted.
Oh my god!
When I have a time limit, it's so bad.
I don't... I don't do well with time limits.
I feel like I waste more time when I have a time limit.
This has to be the slowest behind the scenes feature I've ever done because...
Because I keep getting distracted by things.
Alright, anyway.
So here was like a concept of... Um...
A concept of Flockchamps.
Um... We were like thinking of making more parodies off of Apex in general, but the thing is, I said I wanted like Overwatch and Apex.
Um... So that's why we scrapped this.
Uh... Because I wanted to be more so focused on the fact that I don't want to make it just an Apex parody.
Parody, I want it to be like... Apex and Overwatch.
Because you know, they're both games that um... Are very dear to my heart.
And like basically like I started off like... My career sort of started off because of Overwatch and that's why I wanted to uh... Make it more so like a cumulation of two.
Not like just one game.
Anyway, here's like a concept of what the... Um...
The... The starting screen was gonna look like as well.
So you can see like we're figuring out the GUIs and everything.
And this was what the original idea of the character selection Obviously we went in different direction with the character selection like a lot better.
Okay?
Um...
You know when you load into the game the character selection looked a lot different uh... From before.
So this was what it was originally gonna look like.
And then we also have...
By the way, um...
It's more so like blink and you'll see it.
But like remember when like we saw a dead tomato in the animation?
Uh... That was actually its own model.
Um...
So that... The tomato model.
The tomato model.
The 3D model.
Was actually its own thing.
Like you saw a dead tomato on the floor?
That was a tomato model.
That was a tomato 3D model.
So...
The tomato has its own 3D model.
Um... It's... Yeah.
So it's not like...
You know...
It was actually its own thing.
Um...
Yeah.
It was...
I'm glad we had it.
Like I didn't know... We didn't know what to really do with it until later on.
Cause we were like... Anyway here's the...
I just like... I want a tomato model.
We don't know what to do with it.
But we're just like...
We want it.
You know?
So originally we had an idea.
I scrapped this... I scrapped this idea cause I... I... I...
Um... It was good on...
Um... Like... It was a good idea but I scrapped it.
Because I thought that... Um...
I...
We were... It was originally...
The character select...
Was gonna include...
Other dragoons of my friends.
So you can like select...
We could select my friends as a playable character.
But I scrapped the idea because I was like...
I want them to be skins.
I don't want them...
I want the dragoons themselves...
To be the playable character.
But I want... So like these were icons for like character select.
But I was like... I want the dragoons to be the playable characters.
And then my friends...
To be the skins.
Cause I thought it would make more sense.
Like...
...
Cause I don't know.
I just feel like...
To be more immersive, it would make more sense to...
To make the dragoons themselves be...
The model... Like the actual...
Characters you can pick.
And then you can change the model skins...
With these guys.
So we scrapped that idea.
And that's why we didn't use it.
I'm slowly going through like...
I'm slowly... Oh my gosh.
Here's some background shots by the way.
Like not full background shots.
But like... Here's some...
I need to remember to delete my tabs.
I'm so scared.
I'm gonna get blue screen.
I'm...
I need to remind myself.
Toki delete your tabs or you're gonna get blue screen.
Um...
Here I love background work.
But here's some like...
Uh... Background work.
Uh... Of the...
The tomato reveal trailer.
And... Let's see.
I'm trying to like think... See if there's like...
Stuff... So...
Oh my god.
There's 45 pages.
What were we doing?
We were doing so much.
Oh my god.
My team worked so hard.
It's 45.
There's 45 pages of just...
There's 45 pages of just... Files.
Of just...
Of just like...
Files that were put into this.
This was a lot.
This is the initial...
The initial...
We were starting...
We were starting the 3D modeling.
Uh... Right here.
This is where we were starting the 3D modeling.
Putting stuff in place and everything.
Um...
Guys give me a sec.
I'm scrolling right now.
Give me a sec.
I'm scrolling through everything.
At the moment.
It's not a very like...
What's the word?
...teamless...
...showcase.
There's just so many things.
Um...
Oh yeah.
Here's some concept.
So... I love...
I.
I is like...
I wish we did go with I for the fact that...
I or C.
I wish we did go with I or C.
For the fact that the fucking giant floating...
...dragoon baby.
But...
These were uh...
...map concepts that we had.
For how the map was going to look like.
So I think we had...
It was like...
It was like the set dressing of everything.
I think we went with D in the end.
I think D was the one that looks most familiar to me.
Um... But...
I mean... an art book.
I mean...
Are people actually interested in an art book of this?
Because an art book is a lot.
I spent a lot of money to actually...
I mean, if you guys are actually interested, I can talk to the project team to potentially make an art book of this if they're interested.
Because I definitely will not be able to go through everything.
What about digital PDF?
I mean, I feel like people would definitely enjoy an art book more than a digital PDF because it's a...
I could do both, actually.
I could do both an art book for a collector's edition and just make it limited.
Because art book is a lot of money.
There's a reason why a lot of art books are Kickstarter projects.
Because it is a lot to get a publisher... not publisher, but to get a manufacturer to make art books and stuff.
But I'm down to do it if the project team is open to it as well.
Anyway, here are some concepts as well.
Okay.
And I see here okay, so there's a lot more spaces.
Like, stuff like the map would look like and...
what we had for the map and everything.
Oh my gosh!
Oh my gosh.
There's just...
I did not realize how Many files we have.
Okay, look.
Okay, this was funny.
Because originally, the dragons looked way too complicated.
The initial preliminary sketch of the dragons.
So like, here was like... this is what Axel originally looked like.
And then we simplified it because it would be a bitch to 3D model.
And we felt like it's just too much.
So in the end, it turned into this.
So this is what it turned out into in the end.
So originally, it was like, yeah, super complicated.
And we felt like it didn't really represent some of my friends really well.
So that's why we like mega simplified a lot of the designs when it came to it.
At one point, like... oh wait, let me see.
It was like...
Okay, this is...
This is Altair's...
One of Altair's initial concept.
Which was like...
Like kaleidoscope.
The kaleidoscope ink.
So this was like the initial...
The initial concept of Altair.
Like I said, like everybody went through.
If we do make an art book, I don't think I'm gonna...
I'm not gonna include like...
I guess like...
I'm definitely not gonna include...
I might include like these sketches.
Like the left side.
But not like, you know, screenshots of fucking company old images.
Anyway, here's the concept model of...
Well, like not concept model.
But like it being finished of the...
Of the egg itself.
The loot box itself.
Oh, and also here.
Since we had egg with gun.
Here are...
Um...
Dragoons with guns.
The sequel to egg with gun.
We have dragoons with gun.
Um...
Let's see.
I'm trying to look through some more stuff.
I'm scrolling.
I'm scrolling guys.
Uh...
Oh yeah.
And here's some concept art of...
The sprays itself.
So we went through...
Obviously we made parody.
We made a lot of...
Of...
Um...
Apex sprays.
And here's like some of them.
So the...
Okay.
And I had to pick between the dragoon or tomato.
And I thought the...
Obviously...
I mean not that.
That's not an apex parody.
That's like fucking Saitama.
Saitama parody.
One punch man parody.
But uh...
I had to pick between the dragoon or the tomato.
And clearly I went with the better choice.
Not gonna lie.
Let's see.
All right.
I'm at page 11 guys.
Give it up for page 11.
11!
Woo!
I can't.
God.
I kept them only at page 11.
Like what the fuck.
Uh...
Hahaha.
There's 45 pages.
Oh my god.
This could be like...
If I didn't have another stream, this stream would have gone on for a very long time.
Page 11.
You're almost there.
We're almost there.
Oh yeah.
Here are like sticker concepts too.
Like other...
Um...
Other sticker concepts that we had.
Uh...
So we had other...
Other stickers of everybody else as well as like different types of ideas that we were drafting up.
Um...
And everything.
So these were like some of the sketches and ideas that some of the artists...
The artist that was in charge of stickers and sprays that were...
Um...
That gave us...
And stuff.
Sorry.
I'm not very good with words right now.
Hahaha.
Also, I don't know if you guys know this, but if you look closely at the 3D animation...
Um...
Of the 3D animation, you will notice that the guns have stickers on them.
So these were like concept stickers.
They're not the...
I don't think these were everything, but we actually put like...
We tried...
You know, we made it...
Make it incredibly immersive.
Um...
By the way, the full on credits is in my description.
So, um...
I posted like a credit list of every...
Like, uh...
They made a credits...
Uh...
Sheet of everybody and click on my description.
You'll...
You'll see like cred...
Like a link to everybody.
Hmm.
So, it's more so like if you blink you miss it type deal.
But the guns do actually have like stickers on them.
Um...
To like, you know, make it more immersive as of like, you know, the cost.
Like, you know, the cosmetics of everything.
Uh...
So that it has like cosmetics and stuff.
Um...
Alright.
I'm scrolling.
Guys, I'm on page 12 now.
Page 12!
Give it up for page 12!
We're...
We're getting there!
We're making it guys!
Oh my god!
Sorry, I'm still scrolling through.
Because I want to look at things that I do want to actually show.
There's a lot of like stuff in there that's like, oh we don't have to show that.
We don't.
Oh, here we go.
Here's another concept we had.
So, this one we only were shown two sketches.
Um...
Right here.
Uh...
Obviously, you can tell which one I ended up with.
Because I felt like, you know, A was such a cool action pose and everything.
And I felt like...
You know, I wanted something more like badass.
So, that's why I went with A instead of B.
Because, you know, it looks fucking badass.
Like...
Like, what more do I have to...
Remember to close your tabs, Doki.
You don't want another blue screen.
Remember to close your tabs!
It's just something I tell myself.
Doki, you have to close tabs.
You can't keep everything open.
Um...
But yeah, that is why we went with A.
In general.
Because, like I said, we wanted something that looked like...
Uh...
That we wanted something that looked like, you know...
Something that would look good on...
On...
Um...
On, like...
Uh...
On the splash screen.
And we wanted something more dynamic and more action-y.
Also, here is the initial...
One of the initial concepts for the...
My fake battle net.
Legally designed.
Distinct battle net.
Hahaha.
If I was a game publishing company...
Um...
This is what my...
Uh...
This is what my client will look like.
Um...
So, like I said...
I said I wanted something like Steam or like Battle Net.
Um...
So...
Uh...
Yeah, Battle Bird.
Battlebird.net.
Hahaha.
So, you can see that at first...
It was just like names.
But I requested.
I was like...
Okay.
I want like actual fake game.
I think this was the point where I was like...
I want to include fake games.
Because I don't want Battle Bird to be like the only game on my fake game client.
And I said like to make it more immersive.
The friends we're adding...
They have to have usernames.
Like, I wanted to make it...
Because like we don't put our actual names.
I say as I put Doki Bird as my Steam name.
But like you know what I mean?
Like if we're like, you know...
If we're not just like content creators.
Like we would have like...
We wouldn't put...
Our like...
Our like, you know streamer name as our...
Like on our friends list.
We would have like some fucking dumbass name.
Like...
So that's the point where I was like...
We have to change the...
We have to change some of the names.
Some of the names on some of the friends list.
Because I want to be like, you know...
It's the goon.
So because it's the goon.
I wanted to...
I wanted to make sure that like...
You know, it feels...
Feels more...
I keep saying immersive.
But like that's literally my notes to them.
Every time they're like, what do you think?
I was like change this because I want to be immersive.
Like I want to make it feel like you're...
It could be real.
Like this is something that you can actually see in the future.
But not really because I don't...
I'm not fucking like Gabe.
Like...
I'm not Gabe.
I don't think I can make that...
I don't think I can make this a reality.
But like in an alternate universe, this could be real.
So that's like a lot of my notes.
Even like when we're doing sound design.
Originally there was no...
There was for sound design.
What the very first video I was sent of everything put together.
There was no game sound.
Like game menu sound.
So like, you know, when you're clicking on the game.
It was like click, click beep beep.
Bop bop.
Like, you know, when you're clicking stuff.
Like even like buying something on the game menu or like, you know, scrolling through and like queuing up.
That was not there.
I was like, this is not an immersive.
We need to have like sounds of you clicking stuff.
Of you like when you queue up, it goes click.
When you queue get into a game.
And then when you look at the character select and going through the characters.
There's always a sound there when you pass by to another character.
So like I was very...
Very detailed with like very stickler with the attention to detail.
Because it's the details that makes it like the sound design.
It's literally...
Yeah, the menu sound effects and everything.
That wasn't there.
The menu sound effects weren't there.
So like I specifically was like super anal about that thing.
Those things.
Because like without it, it just seemed like a regular video.
So like the sound design with things like that.
Pushes.
It's just a regular video.
The something that was like, wait, is this real?
Like...
So it makes you be like, oh my God, wait, wait, is this like it makes you doubt yourself.
And it makes you doubt yourself being like, wait, is this real?
Which I saw in chat.
It really did.
Like people were like doubting themselves and be like, oh my God, wait a minute.
Like am I looking at a...
Like, is this going to be released to all of us?
Like...
Anyway, here's another one.
Okay.
I'm going to show this because you might notice something is very different.
This was the original concept for the splash art.
You can see that we changed some of the characters there.
The reason why I changed some of the characters there was because I thought that a lot...
Some of these people were around...
Were already having a lot of fun.
They had their own Easter egg.
So I said like, okay, we're going to have to remove this.
We have to remove that.
Like I removed some people in there only because they already had their own appearances in a different area.
And because of that, we swapped out some of the dragoons there because we want to be fair to...
Because I know there's like other dragons that didn't show up that was in like the stickers and stuff like that.
But we try to make it because I was like, okay, these guys showed up a lot.
They already had...
An appearance in that area.
So I want to swap this...
With somebody else because they didn't have as much screen time as the others.
So that's why like, yeah, this was the original and that's like, remove me.
Because I felt like I just wanted this to be like a dragon splash art.
So I was like, remove me.
I don't want to...
I don't want to be in the saloon right now.
Remove me.
Now.
Now I'm scrolling.
I'm scrolling again, guys.
I'm...
Oh, okay.
These, these, I really want to show you guys.
Cause like, let's see.
I know like, I'm trying to remember which one.
Okay.
Oh, it's the egg.
So I'm gonna show you guys a video.
Because during the character select screen, there were some videos that were not shown because it got cut for time.
So this was one of them.
Which I thought was really cute.
I thought...
Like, you guys didn't see this, but he flipped over.
Which I wanted you guys to see.
I just wanted you guys to see him flip over.
You guys weren't able to see that because it got cut.
It got like cut in half.
This is the character select screen.
So that we had...
I think the others didn't get cut in half as badly as the egg.
So I'm just gonna have that play for a little bit in the background.
While I look for more stuff to show you guys.
Oh my gosh.
I want to show you guys the concepts for some of the game icons.
Because I thought they were really funny.
Oh, here's another one.
Here's another one.
This one.
This is another concept GUI that we had.
Obviously, it got scrapped because the actual one looks a lot better.
But this was some of the other concept art we had going into this.
And oh, here we go.
Okay, I found it.
I found some of the logos and stuff.
There's another logo that we went in.
So here's more like logo concepts and everything.
Let's see.
I'm trying to... I'm scrolling guys.
Guys, I know I'm scrolling.
We're at 22.
Guys, we're getting there.
Oh my god, we're at 22.
Halfway there.
We're halfway there.
Holy shit.
Oh yeah.
You guys might not have seen this.
This is also a blink and you miss it moment type deal.
But here.
So this was the cork board.
Haha.
Uh.
Um.
Behind us during the...
Uh.
During the...
Buh buh buh buh.
What's the word?
Um.
During the animation.
So this was like the dragoons like board in the background.
So like uh you see like you know their vacation photos.
And then you guys trying to draw...
Draw anime.
Hahaha.
Yes.
Uh.
Hahaha.
Oh my god.
Okay.
There was...
I was looking through chat messages.
I was looking through the chat messages and I was like I need Thomas Edison on my friends list.
Cause he's my oh she.
And then someone in the chat was like are we talking...
We're talking about this Thomas Edison right?
Hahaha.
And then...
And then they're like are we talking about this Thomas Edison?
Hahaha.
And then like...
And then they link the picture of Thomas Edison.
Like there's...
There's...
We're not talking about something else right?
This Thomas Edison right?
Hahaha.
They linked the picture of Thomas Edison.
Like I know it's confusing for those who didn't watch the climbing stream.
And you're gonna be like okay like...
Like she's not fucking with us right?
Like that.
Is there like something I should know regarding Thomas Edison?
Like is there somebody else?
Hahaha.
Look okay.
When I say like...
Okay if you heard this with no contest and I'd be like Thomas Edison is my oh she.
Like oh qu...
I...
You'd be confused.
Like it's understandable.
I...
It's understandable why they were...
They were so confused as to like what the fuck is she talking about?
Why does she want Thomas Edison in her game?
Um...
Anyway.
So we also had...
Oh yeah Retro Doki.
This was a Retro Doki's original...
Retro Retro Retro Doki.
Original like uh polygon model.
Um...
I didn't like the hat.
Being like...
Pshhh...
So we changed that.
So this was the original hat of it.
And then we...
We changed it to something like uh...
Uh...
I didn't explain...
Okay look I was like...
He's my oh she.
That's all I need to explain.
Hahaha.
Right?
That's all I need to say.
He's my oh she.
You don't explain your oh she's.
Like it's just your oh she.
Hahaha.
Anyway.
And then this is what it um...
Um...
This is what it ended up look liking...
Uh look like because like I said like I didn't like how the hat protrude a lot.
So I requested that to be changed.
I was like no.
Haha.
No.
I want the hat to look like that.
Hahahahaha.
Alright.
I'm scrolling.
We are at page 26 now.
Guys we're almost there.
We're so close.
Hahahahaha.
I'm looking through if there's like anything like um...
And we do make an oh look oh my god this is so cute though but uh...
This is so cute but look at this.
Look at retro polygon.
Um...
Look at this.
Oh my god.
This is so cute.
I actually really like Retro Polygon Doki.
What the fuck?
This is so cute.
I didn't even see this.
I was so busy I didn't even see this.
Oh my god.
Oh sorry, the staff team really wanted me to show you guys this, but they unintentionally made a dick.
You guys might be like, what does that mean?
Okay, so if YouTube takes this down, you know why.
I'm gonna risk it.
So, this is what the map looked like.
And they accidentally...
They zoomed out and they realized they accidentally made this.
They're like, oh my god, I zoomed out.
Like, what the fuck?
Wait, when did this happen?
When did this happen?
But this is in the map somehow.
I don't know if it's still in it, but this was what... it was there.
Also, here's a scrapped horror.
At first, before we had Duck by Daylight, we had this.
I don't know what the parody was, honestly, but this was like a horror game icon parody of like the rabbits sewn together.
So this was like one of the parodies that we had.
Um... let's see.
I wonder if I sent you my big please respond.
Thank you for the super chat.
No, thank you.
Thank you.
Did I say there's anything else that I want to show you guys?
If there's anything.
Oh yeah, I wonder if we guys saw...
I feel like... no, I've shown some of these before.
Um...
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba.
Oh, we're at 33.
Oh!
Okay, here's another thing I wanted to show you guys.
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba.
Okay, it's a video.
Um... but it is basically the concept.
I think it was a concept video of...
Oh wait, before I show you guys this, but look at this though.
Look at this.
I'm sorry, this was very important for me to show you.
I'm sorry, this was important!
It was so important!
You don't understand!
This is very important.
Anyway, what I actually wanted to show you guys.
This was the original, um...
Anime... uh... the storyboard for, um... how...
It was gonna be the storyboard of like everything.
So like how this was all gonna be done and everything.
So you can see game, company name, Lamal, game name.
Original game theme plays.
But yeah, this was like blocked out.
Or everything.
So...
Maybe... yeah, like finding lobby.
So I'll show you guys this while I look through more concepts.
I've already seen it, so like I don't have to...
I don't have to...
I can multitask and look through this real fast.
Okay.
Um...
But yeah, that was the original concept video of like...
Blocking everything out for everybody.
So they know exactly like, okay, what we sort of need to do.
And like, um...
What... what must be done.
Like what kind of GUI we have to do.
What kind of... uh...
What kind of... um...
Uh...
I guess like...
What assets we need.
We need... what materials.
Uh... Raggy did the animation.
Uh... I believe Boldy did the storyboard.
Like the animation storyboard.
Um... video storyboard.
But I have to double check.
I might be wrong.
Because I can be wrong.
I can be wrong.
I won't...
I won't be surprised if I'm wrong.
I... I...
I'm tired.
There's... there's a lot going on.
That I may or may not remember.
Oh, here we go.
I wanted to show you guys this.
But this was like the original...
Um...
Let's see.
I think this was the original Dokiverse video.
I'm gonna double check.
Because... yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, this was the original Dokiverse logo by the way.
Um... that I'm gonna show you guys soon.
But yes.
Here's the storyboard.
Woo!
It looks so good.
I can't believe Raggy did all...
Like she didn't do the background.
Um...
Um... she wanted to.
But we were like...
No.
Originally she almost decided to do the background.
Anyway, this is what the Dokiverse logo was originally gonna be.
But we changed it.
Because we thought that...
Um...
I don't know.
It looked really plain originally.
So that's why we changed the...
Um... which...
The other one was where it flew in.
I thought like the...
It sliding in just looked way too plain.
So that's why we removed it.
To make it so that it actually like...
Uh...
Flew in and stuff.
Um...
Yeah, like...
The fact that she wanted to do all that herself.
Like...
Originally everything...
A little crazy.
Hahaha!
Like...
Yes.
We're all workaholics here.
But there is like a stopping point.
Of where you have to just stop.
Hahaha!
So...
Yeah.
We did stop her.
Hahaha!
We...
We stopped her.
Um...
Because we were like...
Yeah.
That's...
That's not...
That's not ideal.
That's not ideal at all.
Uh...
Let me say this again.
I don't know if there's anything else that I really want to showcase to you guys.
Oh here.
Look at him.
Look at this big boy.
Alright.
We're gonna call it...
End it here guys.
Look at this big boy.
Woah!
Hahaha!
Next scene.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Imagine wanting to do everything yourself.
Couldn be Doki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm slowly learning how to delegate though.
For real.
I'm slowly learning how to...
Uh...
Delegate to my staff members.
To help me on stuff.
Because like...
I am definitely stretching myself in on a lot of things.
And um...
I've been noticing that.
And...
Because I want to do so many things.
But then I realized that's too many things.
So I'm slowly learning how to delegate and getting my staff members more involved in some of my work.
Um...
And it's been a huge journey.
Oh yes!
The orchestra.
So like I...
Um...
I...
Yes!
Okay.
So...
The reason why I hired this person...
I had four different composers.
Because I wanted to like work with a lot of different composers just to...
Because um...
I think music...
I feel like I wanted...
I wanted more connections within the music um...
Industry...
Okay.
I don't know.
Industry.
I guess like within the music areas in Vtubing.
Because I feel like that's something I heavily lacked in terms of connections.
And like I don't really know like much about music.
In general.
Um...
So that's why like I hired four different composers.
Because I wanted to see like how these four different composers um...
Handle my...
What I want.
Like my music requests.
Um...
Just so like I realize like um...
What it...
And you know I can always have uh...
I can use the music for anything in the future and everything.
So um...
One of them was a composer that specializes in orchestra arrangements.
I didn't think he was gonna actually hire a real orchestra.
Um...
In the beginning.
Because I just wanted like you know I thought he was just...
I...
Originally I was like oh maybe I didn't realize it was like an actual orchestra.
I thought he did it all in his program.
And later he was like do you want me to hire an orchestra?
I was like that's a lot of money.
I was just like I don't know man.
That's a lot of money.
And...
And then he was like no it's okay.
I have actually have a second booking.
Like um...
Actually was gonna use this orchestra for another client.
Um...
And like um...
We can use that booking to also do the songs to the song.
And I was like...
And he'll be like it'll be cheaper.
And then I heard it'll be cheaper.
So then I was like...
Okay.
I did not realize what orchestra he hired by the...
I don't know.
When I saw the invoice...
By the way I need to pay the invoice by the way.
I need to pay the invoice.
But like when I saw the invoice for it.
He also did like three tracks.
But like when I saw the invoice.
I was like this is cheaper.
I did...
I saw it.
I was like this is cheaper.
I didn't know.
Oh my god.
The price for the orchestra.
Apparently I got the cheaper version because I was mooching off somebody else's like booking I was mooching off someone else's like his another clients booking up the orchestra So we technically split the cost for the orchestra.
So I was like holy that was cheaper
Oh my god I was equally as shocked because I didn't realize also I didn't realize this orchestra played for like Famous movies and video games.
I thought he was gonna hire some fucking random orchestra Not some fucking Oscar winning fucking orchestra
I Didn't know but it was worth it.
It was so cool It was it was really cool though in the end I saw the video I was like Jesus Christ, okay
It's the orchestra I was like I was also like no way You guys all saw the video?
I saw the video for the first time too
Even I was like no fucking way It was insane, I was like I'm insane
Oh my god I used I didn't use the back Battle theme, because that was the battle theme that he gave me.
I used the... he made a happy theme that wasn't shown in the video.
There was a happy theme, there was a chill theme, and there was a battle theme.
I used the happy theme in the debut.
Um... but yeah, that shit was insane.
That shit was intense.
Oh my god, it was crazy amazing.
I was so surprised.
Like, it was so cool watching an actual orchestra play, like, something I commissioned.
Um... but yeah, huge shoutout to that guy for making that possible.
Like I said, I commissioned him because I saw that he does, like, orchestra arrangements.
And I didn't realize they were actual, real orchestra arrangements until he, like, told me in the DM.
I was like, you know what?
And then he was like, oh, but it'll be cheaper because we're gonna split the cost of another client.
And I was like, oh, it'll be cheaper?
Okay then, I'll take it.
I'll do it.
You know what?
Fuck it, I'll do it.
And I didn't realize, and I looked at the invoice, and I was like, that was cheaper.
I didn't realize.
It still blows my mind.
I'm like, I like, look at the invoice, like, that's cheaper?
Many, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We need as a BGN to get as much mileage as you can.
Oh my god.
But yeah, oh my god.
That, that, that, that shit was insane.
It was so cool.
It was actually so fucking cool.
Um... I, oh my, I, I, you know, words can actually describe how I feel about the orchestra.
Because when I watched the video, I was like, oh my god, this is beautiful.
I was like, a real orchestra, an orchestra that has played, okay, alright.
Like, it actually played for, like, Genshin Impact 2.
I was like, what the fuck?
It, it's done, like, okay, it's, okay, I need to look at, like, guys, what has it done?
Haha, Wikipedia.
Alright.
It's done so much shit.
I, I don't even know, man.
I don't even know.
I just know it's done, like, a lot of movies and games.
I, I know it, it did, like, orchestra, like, songs for Genshin Impact 2.
It did Skyrim.
It did fucking Skyrim!
Oh my god.
It played music for Skyrim.
Um, and everything.
Um...
But yeah.
Alright, that's all I want to say.
Uh, uh, the entire Faren South... Bro, oh my god.
Put my name in that Wikipedia for the resume.
It, it also did a song for Doki Bird, a random VTube, indie VTuber.
It did a song for a random indie VTuber too, by the way.
Anyway.
Off to my next stream, guys.
I'm gonna call it here.
I need at least, like, 10 minutes of rest before I get into my next stream.
Um, I hope you guys enjoyed the behind the scenes.
I'll talk to the project team if they're open, willing to make an art book out of this.
Um...
Anyway.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and run around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, uh, maybe stay up for a little bit longer, because we're playing Apex next.
Anyway, guys.
See you guys next time.
Or, next stream.
Bye, everybody!
Bye!